when they ran a study of people awarding
hypothetical scholarships to recipients
they would award them more consistently
to people whose politics they agreed
with
even in the face of objective
qualifications or gpa or whatever it was
and apparently most people are fine with
that
that's right because we are fine-tuned
to be sensitive to discrimination based
on race gender and other categories
but we were never taught that
discriminating based on politics with
some horrible taboo political party has
become
a signifier not just of what you believe
in terms of policies but who you are
what your values are what you think
about
you know abortion and war and everything
else you know to have a good society we
have to have well-functioning
institutions
and a good a liberal society not liberal
like left but
you know the traditional notion of a
liberal society
is one in which there is excellence in
different institutions and then people
can live lives that they want to live
and their support from these different
institutions
and now that we're so polarized we don't
trust the other side to run anything
[Music]
all right welcome back to yang speaks
this is zach grauman one of your
co-hosts
thank you for joining we have a
fascinating conversation to introduce
for you today
jonathan height joins yang speaks
and what he talks about with andrew is
something
everybody needs to hear he has something
called the moral foundations
which are basically six principles that
everybody values to various different
scales and it's
a fascinating way to look at why you
lean right or left
so they break this down in depth for a
bit and they talk about human-centered
capitalism and the political divide and
how to use this
moral foundations framework to help
people frankly start talking to each
other so you don't want to miss it
jonathan height on yank speaks
[Music]
it is a thrill and a privilege to
welcome to yang speaks an intellectual
hero of mine social psychologist
modern day philosopher nyu professor
jonathan hype welcome jonathan
thank you andrew it's a thrill to be
talking with you
well i'm going to approve my fandom
right now
uh to everyone by showing people copies
of your books and there are other books
that i'm not holding in my hands right
now
but the righteous mind and coddling of
the american mind
such important works uh and i want to
hear about what you've been doing
since uh your last book but
i have to say that when people ask me
why things aren't working in the country
why
democrats couldn't win seats in november
there are a few books i push them to and
one of them
is the righteous mind i have to say this
book
is so enlightening in terms of why
good moral people are divided by
uh politics and religion though i i
talk about politics more than religion
myself but they're kind of the same
thing nowadays
there is a lot of overlap so
you came to this work i thought in a
really interesting way and like your arc
gets sketched out in the righteous mind
um but how did you
come to be someone who studies morality
for a living so i applied to graduate
schools
and i only got into one at the
university of pennsylvania
and i was originally going to study
cognitive psychology and the psychology
of humor i was going to
figure out why we found things funny um
but it was a real missed opportunity
john you instead of talking to me you
could be talking to some comedian right
now
that's actually a lot of comedians are
doing politics shows nowadays so i i get
to get to do that
actually there's a venn diagram they are
touching it's true yeah
um if you actually maybe there's a third
circle to this which is academics there
would be like comedians
politicians and then academics that's
where i want to be
um so i happen to have a really good
conversation with a professor at penn
who was studying thinking and decision
making and he had a side interest in
moral thinking
and i had done my senior essay in
college on free will and determinism so
i
i just began studying uh morality i
thought it was really interesting and i
began looking at it across
cultures i worked with a wonderful
anthropologist named alan fisk
and in reading ethnographies and reading
stories of you know
anthropologists go to a culture they
lived there for a few years and they
write about
you know marriage or music or food or
something
it became really clear that there's a
lot of similarities
in you know morality is so different in
different cultures but you've got these
weird similarities around like menstrual
taboos or
food taboos everybody has reciprocity
and vengeance
and so i was thinking like okay how do
you reconcile these differences in these
similarities
and so that's what i did for the first
you know about 10 years of my career was
i looked at morality across
nations across cultures but i was i was
a uh you know
i was a democrat i am still a democrat
um and i watched as
you know as the democrats lost in 2000
and 2004 and i just couldn't stand it
anymore and i wanted to
have my research uh be helpful
we'll come to that later as to whether
it's good for professors to be involved
in
politics but but um
uh but it began by 2004 it's really
clear left and right in america were
like
different countries with different
cultures different moralities different
economics textbooks different climate
science textbooks different us
constitution like we were
you know tools of anthropology could now
be applied to america like why
why are we coming apart so i began um
i began writing memos to the democrats
about how to use moral psychology to win
more elections and i didn't really know
any
politicians so like nobody ever read
them i would send them people that would
never read them
um but as the democrats continued to
lose i continued to
you know to to write and to study this
um
and i decided to turn it into a book uh
and then a funny thing happens
so two things happen one is obama won
and now i was not
quite as you know as passionate but it
was like when george w bush was in the
white house it was like
we'd be like you know a lot of democrats
had bushed arrangement syndrome it was
said
and once obama got in then you know sort
of the anger lifted well but but i feel
like bush arrangement uh syndrome would
be like a light cold
uh compared to trump duration syndrome
well that's right well but yeah
similarly yeah george w bush would be a
cold virus and uh i think trump would be
the coronavirus
so um the the over it's not an
overreaction necessarily
um but i started writing the book and
originally my goal was to help
the left but i committed myself to
understanding
all views and i subscribed to national
review and i watched fox news and
and you know there's a lot of bad stuff
you can say about fox news but
exposing yourself to what conservatives
think or you know
to what other people think about an
issue that you care about you
you learn a lot more you see things you
didn't see before
and i came to see that that
conservatives especially sort of berkey
and like edmund burke
conservatives we'll get into that later
about what what the hell is going on
with right now
a lot of it is not conservative but true
conservatives intellectual conservatives
i thought actually made a lot of sense
about what it takes to have a stable and
decent society
and so by the time i got halfway through
the book i decided no this is until the
democrats win
this is to help all of us understand
each other because we are really messed
up by our moral psychology
so when you did those 10 years in other
environments uh like what
countries or societies did you interact
with
it sounds like you were something of
like a world
vagabond during your studies is that
accurate yes i've always loved to travel
and that's actually a feature generally
of the left you know psychologically
you know left and right are different
psychologically like
international love to travel globe
trotting
yeah yes that's it appetite for novelty
corresponds to
uh liberalism so if you really like new
cuisines
uh exposure to different art forms uh
travel then you are more likely to be
liberal or progressive
that's correct and then this is this is
a research by sam gosling
uh if you have a calendar or postage
stamps
uh at your desk you're more likely to be
a republican repub
people on the right are more
conscientious more organized people on
the left are
are less conscientious less organized um
if the meeting starts on time it's
probably a right-wing meeting if it's
late it's probably a left-wing meeting
so there's all kinds of interesting
research on that wow
that that's why i guess they talk about
college time like everyone shows up late
yeah we could we could see whether uh
it's different that there are a couple
of conservative universities we could
see if i bet classes start on time there
um but i did my
dissertation research in brazil because
i spoke spanish and
i was hoping to find a collaborator in a
spanish-speaking country at a conference
in argentina
but um but people in the
spanish-speaking countries were mostly
doing psychoanalytic
marxist stuff and i found a great
collaborator in brazil
and um she you know she did the research
there so anyway i did my original
research in brazil and then i worked
with an amazing anthropologist richard
schwader
who had connections in india so then i
went to bhubaneswar india which is the
capital of
the state of orissa and that really blew
my mind that's where i really first
began to
i think understand the conservative
mindset i hated conservatives before
then
and so i wouldn't be nice to american
conservatives but
in india it's you know it was a
traditional society
hierarchical sex segregated religious
and
they were very nice to me and i liked
them and that opened my heart and i
could understand
at least some of the things that
conservatives value
uh so that for me was like the matrix
moment like the red pill moment
when i stepped out of my you know
left-wing american moral matrix and
began to look at it from the outside
more as a social scientist
so brazil india those would be very very
different experiences
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by athletic greens
so i've learned to love this stuff i've
never been a big
diet supplement guy this one's pretty
easy either comes in you can do it in
like a bowl
there's a big bowl you can buy or you
can get like these little daily pouches
but you throw it in some water
it's tasty it's great and for me on
personal level it just helps it just
helps me digest things better
like no stomach pains whatever i eat
what i want um
helps work out and i also know i'm
getting all those vitamins i'm supposed
to be getting
um in a healthy uh nutritious way so
um it's essentially the most
comprehensive daily nutritional
beverage i've tried probably
out there in general so it's got you get
one scoop of this stuff it's got 75
vitamins
and minerals and the whole food source
ingredients
um there's a multivitamin in there
there's multi-mineral probiotic green
superfood blend
and more and they all work together to
fill the nutritional gaps in your diet
so
sometimes i don't eat enough vegetables
sometimes i don't eat enough
get enough vitamins or various proteins
things like that and it nails it for you
so i like it i take every morning it's
great and it tastes pretty freaking good
so
here's the deal athletic greens has this
awesome dietary supplement that works
with any diets here
keto paleo vegan whatever the heck you
are it fits with all of it
and what they're doing is they're
doubling down on their awesome product
and giving you in addition to your first
purchase on athletic greens
giving you a one-year supply of vitamin
d which i have it's pretty great
and then five free travel packs so you
can try out the travel pack as well with
your first purchase if you visit the
link today
all you gotta do visit
athleticgreens.comyang
join the health experts athletes health
conscious go-getters and
myself and andrew um as people around
the world who are using this
making that daily commitment to actually
feeling better and eating better and
having that healthy diet
every single day athleticgreens.comyang
get your free supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs with them
right now
one of the most fascinating aspects of
your book
was identifying different moral values
that transcend
nationality or society that there are
things that just human beings
are wired for and you mentioned one of
them which is reciprocity which is if
someone
does something nice for you then we're
wired to be nice to them
and you can see that uh you know you and
i are parents you can see that with
infants where if like you smile
they're likely to smile back it's kind
of like like most of the
the interaction you have and so you're
identifying these six universal
moral values i thought was so important
and those moral values you identified
were
uh caring fairness
sanctity loyalty authority and then you
also identified liberty
and if you look at these values
uh liberals and progressives tend to
operate more on the
caring and fairness dimensions and
conservatives tend to
operate more along the lines of
uh sanctity loyalty and authority right
social liberty being interpreted yeah
social conservatives that's right yeah
with liberty being
interpreted and valued slightly
differently uh
by each side that's right so that you
know i
i love metaphors and the human mind is a
pattern matcher we think in metaphors
so if you have a good metaphor makes it
easy to understand something
so the metaphor that i think is best
here is you know our our we all have the
same
tongues more or less and our tongue you
know if you're a human being your tongue
has five taste receptors for
sweet sour salt bitter and umami which
is kind of a meat flavor
uh because we evolved our ancestors ate
meat and fruit and so those guide us to
the right things
so we all have the same taste receptors
but
depending on what culture you grow up in
you have a different cuisine and maybe
you know it
i like i thought america had a lot of a
lot of sweetness but then i went to
chile in chile they consume more sugar
than anyone on earth
and like everything everything is so
sickly sweet in
chile but that's what they're used to um
and
other cuisines are spicier and have you
know um
anyway the point is we have an evolved
nature that guides us to things that
were good for our ancestors and we have
cultural nature that grew up
historically based on local
circumstances
and it's the same thing with morality so
care is the easiest one to understand
because
we're mammals and what it means to be a
mammal is that you nurture
you're young for a long time you have
huge parental investment
and for most mammals it's only the
female that makes the investment but in
humans and
a few other species males fall in love
with their kids and make make the
investment too
so we all have tremendous sensitivity to
suffering and we see
you know like that famous photo of a of
a two
a two-year-old washed up on the beach in
in southern europe
that was you know so powerful for during
the uh immigration uh issue in europe
we all are wired to respond now
conservatives love their children and
and
and have sympathy for suffering but
conservative morality is not based
primarily on that
whereas left-wing moralities especially
modern western left-wing
is based much more on compassion care um
how you think society should be ordered
is based on that foundation
conservatives have that foundation but
their morality is not heavily based on
it
fairness second one as you said
reciprocity our our ancestors are
revolved to trade we we trade not just
things we trade insults we trade
um favors so reciprocity is very deep in
us and
if you do something for someone and they
don't reciprocate we we
hold on to that we resent that we have a
strong sense of people who take more
than they give
uh but in some cultures uh you
you have such a rigid such attention to
direct fairness
that if that if somebody you know
insults somebody in your family
you now have to insult someone in theirs
or it quickly escalates to a feud and
you
you know violence and in other
subcultures it's turned the other cheek
or
just brush it off so we all have the
same moral foundations but
different cultures construct them
differently and as you said the social
conservatives in the united states
um uh they they do their
you know they rely on care to some
extent fairness for them
is proportionality if you do the crime
you do the time
whereas fairness on the left is more
about equality and nowadays especially
quality of outcome
and if you have disparities if you have
one group is doing better than another
that
looks on the surface to be unfair
because it's unequal
so we all talk about fairness but we
mean something different
and then liberty uh is kind of similar
on the left and the right except that on
the left
people see corporations and rich people
as the oppressors as the ones that need
to be overthrown
historically going all the way back to
marx whereas on the right
the american right it's government
there's a real suspicion of government
is is the bully and you know we have to
arm ourselves and second amendment and
all that
um so those three foundations are are
used by both sides but they mean
something different
and then loyalty authority and sanctity
those three are heavily used by social
conservatives and they are largely
rejected
by by the modern left because those seem
those are the
the psychological foundations of
tribalism of group loyalty
if you know fascist country fascist
morality is very heavily based on
group loyalty authority to the the
strong man
and a sense of sanctity or purity about
the motherland things like that
um so any culture war in america
you know like flag you know the american
flag though you know it's uh if you're
on the left
well burning the american flag is a kind
of free speech but if you're on the
right the flag is sacred it's not just a
piece of cloth
so um so what i found from reading
ethnographies and looking at evolution
was
morality varies but the sort of the deep
psychological structures of it are
universal and once you understand that
now the way is open if you're a democrat
and you want to appeal
to to moderates and conservatives
don't frame it in terms of you know
oppression or suffering
frame it in terms of you know the the
you know the great american promise or
what's great about america or
um you know american traditions or
so you know something like that you can
you can you can couch almost any appeal
uh in you can ground it in foundations
that your listener
responds to i had this experience
countless times
on the trail i thought of you sometimes
uh john you should know
so i'll give you one example i
am for universal health care i think it
makes perfect
sense it makes no sense not to have
universal health care particularly in
this context
it makes zero sense to tie it to jobs
given that the majority of jobs now are
temporary gig or contract jobs and you
don't get benefits a lot of time
but when people ask me about universal
health care the way a lot of
folks frame it is in uh it's a human
right
and there is this uh caring
argument which i agree with 100 i mean
it's inhumane and
savage and barbaric that we have people
that don't have health care
but the way i would frame it often and i
totally believe this too so it wasn't a
stretch for me
was look imagine all of the americans
who never started a small business never
changed jobs never made some kind of
um independent venture
happen because they were stuck in a job
that had health care
and they knew that they would lose their
health care if they lost it that
if you're a pro entrepreneurship pro
business creation pro risk taking
you should be for universal health care
too because this is just awful
for any form of economic dynamism uh and
i
completely i believe that i mean it's
true i've run a business
and like that they're you know like this
healthcare system does keep people fixed
in place in ways that's that's not
um very positive um but that's an
argument that would work
unlike a different set of americans
exactly
then that's right the caring and
fairness argument that's right because
the right so ronald reagan gave us the
mod well
ronald reagan created the coalition of
um
of social conservatives um uh
and business conservatives or or laissez
faire capitalists who are not
conservative in any way they're uh uh
you know pro-business but they're not
social very different social
conservatives
um and the third group is authoritarians
uh
people who are prone to racism when
triggered by the sense that that our our
moral order is coming apart so
psychologically there's three very
different groups social conservatives
um uh libertarians or laissez faire
conservatives and capitalists
and authoritarians so he united those
three into a very powerful coalition
and the authoritarians were never in the
driver's seat they're less educated
they're more racist
uh they were never in the driver's seat
and that's what's unique about our era
is that the social the true social
conservatives who have a lot of respect
for
um a lot of them are anti-trump a lot of
them were you know are
sort of kicked out of the club uh so the
never trumpers a lot of those are
berkey and conservatives um and the
authoritarians for the first time
have at least the president's ear uh
they they are much more influential in
the modern right
coalition so it's kind of a mess now and
you know i have you know in the book you
can tell i think that i have a lot of
respect for conservatives and
libertarians
but as as well as as well as the left
but um
but the but in the last four years the
republican party i think has kind of
lost its mind
because that reagan coalition is really
changing
and it's not conservative in any way
that i can recognize
genuine conservatives looking up being
like wait a minute like why did we just
why don't we sign off on things that are
going to
um expand the deficit when we're
supposed to care about the deficit which
by the way i think carrying about the
deficit in an historic pandemic is like
uh
the wrong thing to do i mean you know
the house is on fire you got to put the
fire up
um but they're like traditional
conservative values the republican party
is completely abandoned
and i thought that the the biggest
example of it was when they refused to
even
write down a platform for their
convention
because they were afraid that trump was
just going to go against it at any
moment so they said you know what let's
let's just leave the platform blank
the platform was essentially whatever
trump's saying today that's going to be
our platform
like it was a complete abandonment of
any kind of
consistent principle no that's right and
that reflects something that
i think ezra klein has really called
attention to in his book why we're
polarized
uh and you know he's drawing on
political scientists in this
um but it's that in recent years uh our
politics has really shifted away from
being about issues and being almost
entirely about
identity and so uh people aren't going
to vote based on what the platform is
it's you know is your identity
uh you know is it you know are you
by race or gender or sexual orientation
is that part of your identity
is your identity i'm a real american and
they're not real americans
so uh you know trump capitalized on on
that
um and uh you know it's transforming the
right because as you say
these issues that they that seemed so
near and dear to them that
extent that many were very principled
those all have been thrown out the
window
um one of the most important values is
respect for process
the so you know traditional
conservatives they seem it might seem a
little
uptight or rigid but you know like
here's the process this is what
you know this is what gets done uh and
you know now
what we're seeing with this challenge
you know trump's challenge to uh
you know to the election i mean you know
sure make appeals
he did that and they went through the
process and they were rejected
but um but and the fact that so many
republican congressmen and senators
are joining him in basically you know
have no respect for the process
rejecting the process all they care
about is the outcome
uh or i guess we should say in the case
of the senators and and um
and congressmen they're the media's
ecosystem and the republican party is
such that
they're afraid of getting primary
they're afraid of of being a target of
the president so i don't know how many
of them really believe
that the election was stolen i have no
way to know that but
man it's it's a mess of a party and it
sure ain't conservative
yeah it's very dark you have people
arguing uh
count the vote and stop the vote in
different places just depending upon
what they think is going to help their
team which is like a v parody
[Laughter]
it's in real life why we're polarized by
ezra klein
joins the righteous mind in
to me explaining why things are so bleak
for us i mean literally the book's
called why we're polarized so it
explains why we're polarized
but one of the the things he said that i
think most people would find shocking
is that there is a very low correlation
between one's policy viewpoints
uh and one self-identification as
conservative or liberal
uh that if there was a perfect
correlation which is i say i'm
conservative and then all my policies
line up as conservative it would be like
a a one
correlation on a scale of zero to one
which would be perfect now you wouldn't
expect anything to be perfect
but the correlation that ezra found in
studies was 0.25
which is really low
that's very very low and he explained it
in a way that made sense to me he said
look the fact is most americans
uh don't think in white papers they
haven't really thought about
a lot of these policies in depth um they
just know what team they're on they know
what tribe they're a part of
and the communications they're getting
at this point
are very much about activating what team
you're on
um as opposed to nuanced policy
yeah i think that's right because the
political parties
um didn't used to be perfectly sorted by
left right there used to be conservative
democrats and liberal republicans
there was overlap in values but
beginning you know some historians of
political scientists say beginning with
johnson signing the civil rights act
and he said to bill moyers uh right
afterwards i've just signed over the
the south to the republican party for
the rest of my life and yours
so that shifted southern conservative
democrats over to being southern
conservative republicans
uh and you know so the the and the
republican party kind of radicalizes
first
he get fox news in the 90s so for a lot
of reasons the republicans purify
and and radicalize in the 90s uh by the
90s
um and the democrats uh uh
are still more diverse at the time but
were spread out at the time but i think
social media has had a quite an effect
on the democrats so the democrats
recently have moved especially white
democrats have moved much further to the
left on us on a bunch of issues
so uh we have purified parties we have a
social media ecosystem that can kind of
enforce
uh you know can punish people who stray
and so for a lot of reasons and ezra's
book does a great job of really
covering the territory of research for a
lot of reasons
polarization has been rising steadily
since the 80s and especially since the
year 2000.
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is sponsored
by better help
so i don't know about you i've said this
before i'm gonna keep saying again the
pandemic is messed with my head man
i have not been i've not been myself
i think in quarantine and i feel like if
you're like oh i'm fine you're probably
lying to yourself i think we're all
really really struggling there's so much
going on in the world
the future of this country doesn't look
great and then the future of us like
just
as humans has been really really harsh
um
and there's days where you don't always
want to get out of bed or there's days
where you're just feeling tired or just
lack of purpose because we're all
working remotely that human connection
is is lagging
and um for me it's interfering with
happiness or just like my effectiveness
i don't feel as effective so i started
using
betterhelp one of the cool things about
the podcast we get all these sponsors
that i never would have found myself and
then
um i try them and if i like them we
bring them up here and same with andrew
um
betterhelp is pretty freaking cool
because
it frankly for me it's just someone to
talk to so it's between you and your
counselor
um it's available all over the world no
matter where you are you can check this
out and they've got counselors
you just talk to you on pretty much
anything depression stress
anxiety or relationships grief uh
coveted laziness like whatever's driving
you nuts um
and it's all confidential it's
convenience professional affordable and
and we
have always been really big about mental
health um and particularly now like this
is a rough time to not be in a good head
space so
if you listen to this podcast uh you get
10 off uh your first month
with better help so if you visit our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang you can join over one million
people who have taken charge our mental
health like
us uh that's better help help dot com
slash yang
[Applause]
ezra says a lot of things that i think
are really important but one thing he
said was that
discrimination against someone based
upon their political ideology is like
the last acceptable form of
discrimination
for like for millions of americans
uh and it's so extreme that when they
ran a study
of people awarding hypothetical
scholarships to recipients
they would award them more consistently
to people whose politics they agreed
with
even in the face of objective
qualifications or gpa or whatever it was
and apparently most people are fine with
that
that's right because we are fine-tuned
to be sensitive to discrimination based
on race gender and other categories
but we were never taught that
discriminating based on politics was
some horrible taboo
and as political party has become a
signifier not just of
what you believe in terms of policies
but who you are what your values are
what you think about
you know abortion and war and everything
else
of course you can discriminate against
people who are evil of course you should
treat them differently
there was a i gave a talk in 2011 about
how my field social psychology was
purifying politically
you know academics have have leaned left
for more than 100 years
and psychologists have always leaned
left but there were conservative
psychologists
and by 2011 i i did a search for a
conservative social psychologist i was
only able to find one
i gave a talk on that and afterwards
some social psychologist wanted to see
whether i was exaggerating or
and they surveyed about five or six
hundred people in the in the field
and one of the things they did was they
asked if you know if somebody was
applying for a job and you found out
that they were
conservative or liberal would that you
know would you be less likely to
to award it or if if you were rewarding
um uh
grants or you know all sorts of other
things and
the the majority of people in my field
said that they would at least to some
extent discriminate against
conservatives and about 40 percent said
that they would do so to a substantial
degree
because it's fine that's not
discrimination that's just like good
judgment
uh and so that's rough yeah and
yeah and of course the and you know and
most of the research shows these biases
are generally pretty symmetrical so you
know the right does it
does it to the left uh but yeah it's a
mess because
you know to have a good society we have
to have well-functioning institutions
and a good a liberal society not liberal
like left but you know
the traditional notion of a liberal
society is one in which there is
excellence in different institutions and
then people can live lives that they
want to live and their support from
these different institutions
and now that we're so polarized we don't
trust
the other side to run anything and we
don't respect the institution
so police has always leaned right the
academy is always lean left
so you know on the left they don't trust
the police on the right they don't trust
professors
so yeah it's making it hard to have a
good society and and this is a time when
we really need to get our institutions
working
if we're going to have everybody rising
if we're going to have a more inclusive
form of capitalism i hope we can talk
about that
uh human-centered capitalism i mean i'd
be thrilled to i'd be thrilled to talk
about human-centered capitalism
uh so one of the findings in your book
that blew my mind and then ezra
presented it
in a similar way was that there are
these
psychological underpinnings that are
associated with
uh our political inclinations and so you
and i referenced earlier
appetite for novelty if you like new
stuff you're more likely to be
liberal or or progressive uh other
qualities there's a
psychological quality of openness that
like if you're more open
and this this this sounds like it's all
sort of like good for
uh progressives and liberals i mean you
talked about conscientiousness
corresponding to conservatism
and and that has many many positive
characteristics uh where uh
generally people think of being
conscientious is a very good thing
um that there is another one around
threat sensitivity
where if you are
more mindful of uh dangers then you're
more likely to be conservative and there
are times where that could be
exactly what you want like depending
upon the the context
uh there's another one around disgust
reflex which is if i show you something
um kind of gross like do you uh
like you know react adversely or or
do you shrug and there are times when
you can say well
you know you probably should be very
concerned about something
um that's unclean if for example you're
like looking for
you know stuff to eat in a particular
environment or whatever it happens to be
but the the most compelling thing and
this is as a parent i've got
uh two children you've got is it uh two
children yeah as well
two children yeah so if you're a parent
you know that
your kids are different from each other
in a way that has nothing to do with
anything you did
you know i've i've i've got two boys and
they're pretty distinct
uh and it turns out that these
psychological
qualities correspond to
um someone's nature when they're born
and that these things can lead someone
to
certain political leanings uh and so
this strikes me as really fundamental
where wait a minute
if your nature actually drives you
towards conservativism or liberalism
then it really should be very
problematic for me to
uh like castigate demonize or villainize
millions of people based upon their
politics that's right
that's a good way that's a good way to
put it so i'd say the biggest discovery
in psychology in the last
50 years is that almost every trait that
you can measure about a person
is going to be to some degree heritable
which means that if you look at the
clear
demonstrations if you look at identical
twins who are separated at birth it
doesn't happen much anymore but it used
to happen
if you look at identical twins separate
at birth raised in different families
they will tend to be similar on levels
of religiosity and politics now what
religion is chosen by the parents
but how religious they are um is is
affected very heavily by their genes and
the similarity of twins reared apart
increases over time now you'd think that
like oh if they have different
experiences they would
get more different but actually no once
they get out of their parents house
and they can choose things for
themselves they tend to choose the same
sort of thing
fraternal twins don't do this they're
not very similar but identical twins
tend to be very similar
and so so if yeah if political
orientation
is something intrinsic and innate like
sexual orientation
um that is uh that is one ethical reason
why we should be
at least conscious or think about
whether it's legitimate to discriminate
people
against people obviously you can choose
who you associate with but in terms of
hiring or anything else is is
might politics have some similarities to
the other forms of identity that we're
more used to dealing with
well you referenced fox earlier i did
appear on fox
as a candidate uh one of the things that
i found is very compelling or telling
is that fox's ratings are higher than
cnns and msnbc's by a very significant
margin
and and one of the arguments you make in
the righteous mind is that this moral
vocabulary that speaks to conservatives
is actually
slightly more popular than
the other moral vocabulary so to all
of the progressives uh who are
listening to this gnashing your teeth
being like why the heck
like does it seem like uh like the
audience on the other side is bigger
it's because of
um the this moral vocabulary that's
right we can go even deeper on that it's
not just a matter of vocabulary
um so there's a really good book out now
by by my friend joe henrik he's a
professor at harvard in uh evolutionary
biology
economics anthropology he's a really
great social scientist
and so the book is called the weirdest
people in the world and weird
stands for western educated
industrialized rich and democratic
and the thesis is the finding is that
people like you and me people in media
journalism the academy
um in any almost any area of elite
society uh have this have this way of
thinking
which is very different from the other
you know 95 of humanity
so most of humanity thinks that kin ties
are very important
and group loyalty is very important and
they're more
rooted uh and it's the weird people who
are the exceptions
and then with a student at the
university of virginia thomas tallheim
he did all kinds of really cool research
on how rice farming
regions of china and india create a very
different morality than wheat farming
regions
so he's been publishing that he looked
to see whether
the left-right difference matches on and
sure enough it does people on the left
in america and in china are more weird
in their cognition
than our people on the right and so what
that means
is that is that people on the left
should really see themselves as the
exceptions
it doesn't mean it's bad in any way it
just means
progressives think like a very small
percentage of humanity
and that's why i say in the righteous
mind one of my chapters is entitled the
conservative advantage
because right-wing politicians have a
built-in advantage they can play on more
keys
as it were or they can appeal to more
taste buds uh progressives
are always at risk of just thinking
everyone's like me but they're not
people are not mostly like progressives
yeah i had a conversation with anand
girdardos recently where
uh he and i both made the same um
argument that like we just need to talk
about some of these things
by appealing to different values than we
currently are
because if you sit someone down and i
did this hundreds or thousands of times
on the trail
where if you sit down a conservative and
you say hey
do you think drug prices are too high
they'll be like heck yeah you know like
do
do you think that someone should have
health care if they lose their job also
heck yeah
you know it's like like that like if you
communicate things in certain ways and
people
are on board with it um if you were to
ask that person are they for
medicare for all they might say heck no
because that's been coded very
negatively
by their their favorite journalist or
whatnot
um so a lot of it is about changing
terms
um no when i presented universal basic
income as the freedom dividend
you know we did so in part because we
found it appealed to
uh different types of voters and it
appealed to
liberals and democrats at the same level
so it's like oh why not you know
if you're going to help it but i want to
caution you here because
um what you're doing is you're talking
about framing and you're talking about
and a couple times in our conversation
you've talked about the terms that you
use or the you know framing or what
words you use
um the left was profoundly affected by
george lakoff's book don't think of an
elephant and by george lakoff's work in
general
and lakov is great i mean his his lake
often johnson metaphors we live by is
one of the most important books i i've
ever read
uh and his his work on moral politics is
fantastic also
but um he used the example of the the
death tax as a brilliant
framing device yes the estate tax turn
into the death that's right
so yes that's a great example that's
very viscerally powerful
and a lot of democrats seem to have
latched on to that example and that book
don't think of an elephant
and they're uh they just think about
okay let's get the right frames if we
get the right
our policies are better so if we can
just get the right frames and the right
words it'll be like magic it'll
you know it'll go right into their heads
and it like a lock and key it'll turn
and then they'll vote for us
and that's been the idea since 2004 and
there was a great book by
matt bai called the argument i think was
around 2006 2007
where he he traces the democrats efforts
to come up with this like master
narrative and the frame and to try to do
this and
uh by 2006 2007 they had made almost no
progress
and here we are it was especially clear
i think with hillary clinton's campaign
you know okay what is your campaign
about
what is you know what what do democrats
stand for you could list a couple
policies but the point is they didn't
make much progress on that
so i'd like to suggest to democratic
politicians you got to go beyond framing
it's not just about words you have to
show that you actually have some respect
for some insights
on the other side you have to listen uh
and then you have to
talk talk in ways that that appeal to
their
things that they really value and so
your example is
of of talking to about health care in
terms of
dynamism the economy is great because
the you know the right the social
conservatives
are in with the libertarians and the pro
the pro-business side they hate
handouts they hate welfare they think
people should work and pull themselves
up so if you say well if people want to
work but often
you know they're trapped because you
know in a
job because of healthcare they won't
take chances um so the more you can say
you know i hear you we need a dynamic
economy and
we want everyone to have a stake in the
economy and we want people to love
capitalism
[Music]
yang speaks is sponsored by skillshare
you guys gotta check this out because
the way to learn cool new stuff
particularly in the creative realm i
think i've said it before i'm taking
this class
through skillshare it's called plants at
home uplift your spirit and space
because i always i'm kind of envious
when people have like
green or shrubbery and greenery in their
homes and i always kill them so i've
learned not to over water my plants like
a dumbass and i've learned a bunch of
other things about how to
kind of make i got a new apartment like
how to make a home uh
a little bit better with some greenery
and how not to kill it and how to
balance it out so it's pretty cool but
there's a whole bunch of other class
they got classes on iphone photography
they've got stuff on how to be creative
on creative online they've got stuff
called find your style five exercises to
unlock your creative identity like
there's stuff on illustration graphic
design photography film video
productivity ui ux design creative
writing
whole bunch of different ways to learn
from other people with these skills to
unlock your own and it's pretty
freaking cool so it's this online
learning community
and it's a real fun way to grow this
year in 2021.
it's also not that expensive uh it's
incredibly affordable
especially compared to some of these
pricing in person classes so it's like
literally less than ten dollars a month
um and for us you're gonna get a free
trial
so if this is peaking your interests it
peaked mind
i'm learning about plants but if you
don't learn about plants learn about a
whole bunch of other stuff i just
mentioned uh check it out
skillshare.com get a free trial of a
premium membership that's
skillshare.com yang
[Music]
[Applause]
let's talk about ubi and how to frame
that and also human-centered capitals
because that's where we're going here in
the conversation
how do you sell how do you sell promote
how do you
co what do you find is effective because
especially ubi
i would guess is much more acceptable on
the left but the idea of people in the
to people on the right of a handout
everybody gets 12 you know 12 000 a year
they don't have to do anything that
right on its face is contrary to
conservative morality
so tell me how you sell that or what
what appeal has worked
one of the things i talked about a lot
on the trail was how the market gets a
lot of important things wrong
and i ask how much does the market value
the work that my wife evelyn does with
our two children every day one of whom
is autistic
and then they say zero and then i say
well
we all know that's ridiculous that the
work she's doing is some of the most
important work
that anyone can ever do and
this goes true for every stay-at-home
mother every caregiver
every person who's taking care of a
loved one
and i found that many social social
conservatives
like that message a lot because they're
very pro-family
they believe in people
taking care of each other and my message
was around
trying to divorce this market based
economic value from this intrinsic human
value
and i think there was something um
kind of both communal and
and even sacred about the way i was
presenting this intrinsic human value
we found that over time the
appeal of universal basic income when i
started it was not very high
it truly was like at the i think it was
like the high 20s or something along
those lines
nationwide as we're having this
conversation
um it's above 55 last i checked
um and cash leave during the pandemic is
something like 85
yes including a majority of both uh
democrats and republicans um so those
were some of the arguments i made that
seem
to appeal to people on both sides okay
so
a couple times in our conversation
you've made arguments that begin with
like utility or or conceptual
distinctions like saying the market
misprices certain things
um and you know uh but then you got to
um you know the family appeal so i would
suggest
the general principle for i think for
politics and persuasion is
talk to speak to the elephant first you
know if the mind is divided
like a ride around an elephant where the
writer is your conscious reasoning
the elephant is is the intuitions and
emotions the other 95 percent of what's
going on in your mind
uh if people have a visceral sense that
they don't trust you or they don't
like you or they think your policies are
threatening then
no amount of reason or fact or evidence
is going to change their mind
i found that on the trail for what it's
worth like a lot of it
that's one reason why if you talk to a
professional
um media consultants or politicos
most of it's about trying to make people
like you
it's a lot of like my ads were like
andrew yang
patriot job creator parent like all the
stuff where
frankly i found it a little bit um
uncomfortable
or difficult but they were like no no if
they like you then anything you're
you're doing they'll like too
okay well if it's just you know like me
like me like me
uh you know that so you know demagoguery
is just speaking to the elephant and not
caring about reasons and evidence uh and
political consultants
often you know they be just as well-off
advising demagogues uh you know but
you're an evidence guy a social science
guy you read you know you read books you
you know you want policies that will
work uh
so so for you you basically get it but i
would advise you to
even go more on that um you know talk
about it
talking for example talking about uh you
know the breakdown of the family i mean
this is something that the right has
been right about since the 60s
and you know patrick you know patrick
moynihan you know wrote a report on this
and he's been you know
and sociologists have finally realized
moynihan was really right and that
strong families are essential i made
this argument on the trail john i said
look we should be subsidizing
marriage counseling for anyone who wants
it uh and then there are there are folks
that
um you know said why and then i said
well because the data shows that
children who grow up in a two-parent
household are more likely to have all
sorts of positive outcomes
and you know i'm a data guy so like that
that's a slam dunk like
if you can keep a family together it's a
win for the next generation but
if you if you have an audience that is
of centrists or moderates and and
conservatives
i would urge you to start by
acknowledging
that you might even say you know
um you know they're they're all these
policy
debates and with the in the benefit of
hindsight we see that you know each side
was right about some things and
you know modern social science research
shows that you know conservatives were
right to be concerned about the family
and
the decline of family the rise of
divorce um and
uh i think you know you know even though
i'm a democrat or a liberal i you know i
i like good you know truth wherever i
find it
um but something to validate that they
were right about that that it is
it is the most humane way to care for
people in most cases
um so start really you know um start
with
you know talk to the elephant first uh
uh acknowled
uh acknowledge their concerns uh and
then you can give the data to back it up
that's what i mean by
then you speak to the right the writer
second i do tend to reverse that
a lot yeah no right in this conversation
you've done it a couple times
yeah and that's and that's right yeah
you know like off lake off
so lakov had his book uh uh moral
politics i think it was called and then
um oh what's the other one the political
brain um
what drew weston uh a couple years later
so the two of them
both made similar arguments that the
democrats tend to speak to the head they
tend to give data
and that's why they have such trouble
connecting so
you know knowing that and that's why
bill clinton was such a genius i mean
clinton and obama both
uh you know clinton in particular
because he was from the south and
uh um but you know he was very talented
at
speaking to the right to speak to the
elephant first so one another appeal i
made on the freedom dividend that you
might enjoy john as i talk about people
as the owners and shareholders of the
richest society in the history of the
world
said that uh this is this is a dividend
on our phenomenal progress of the last
number of decades our economy is up to
22 trillion dollars
we can easily afford a dividend of a
thousand dollars a month for people
and i have to say folks did often ask me
at the time like where are we going to
get the money
and then i would talk about amazon
trillion dollar company paying zero in
taxes etc
but now post pandemic no one asks where
you're gonna get the money because now
it's pretty clear we could just could
have done
anything that's right so so if
you look at the look at the usual
polarities and you want to break them up
if you can
and you know the left right polarity for
more than 100 years has been
labor versus capital it's on the economy
um
and the left tends to be uh
anti-capitalist and the far left is
always clearly strongly anti-capitalist
and uh that means that the the right
can always point to people on the left
and saying they're socialists they hate
capitalism they
hate america um and you know they're
always they're trying to scare voters
with the
the boogeyman of socialism or communism
and
when you know when uh democrats have
come out
and said um you know no you know
capitalism
is great i mean it's um you know it's
what has made america
uh strong and wealthy and successful and
we
invented the modern form of it etcetera
etcetera you know make it part of
american identity
uh and also free mark you know the word
free market is is
is also good um but if you come out and
you break up the polarity by saying no
you know
you know capitalism is a good thing but
it always has it has this brutal side
creative destruction
it's not just an abstraction like
people's lives are destroyed when
industries close down or automation is
you know as you say you know it's a good
thing overall but my god
it's going to re destruction on
hard-working people
and so you break up the binary in that
way you're pro-capitalist
but you totally understand the the
critiques of the left of capitalism have
real merit
and that's why my policy will et cetera
et cetera
but you got to resonate with their
concerns first and make it clear you're
not the boogeyman you actually agree
with them about some basic values
that's one reason we framed it as
human-centered capitalism i'm not
talking about framing but i genuinely
believe
that this version of capitalism has lost
its mind and its soul and is
destroying tens of millions of lives and
that that's more true
uh now than it even was when i was
running uh
so to me the goal should be to try and
harness capitalism to benefit
the average family in iowa or ohio
or new york city or wherever uh because
right now
our capitalist system is geared towards
uh stock market prices and capital
efficiencies
financial trying to make the the world's
first uh
trillionaire or whatever the heck that
you know jeff's going to become at some
point
if things keep up like that that's the
way the winner take all economy
uh is not trying to help us
and one of the things i was saying was
look the capitalist economy does not
care about a cashier or truck driver
that loses their job because a computer
can do the job better
and pretending that our system somehow
are going to account for that human
being
is stupid but we should
and so we we need better measurements we
need better goals
we need better data and benchmarks
uh we need a president who's going to
say look
like our goal should be to get deaths of
despair
down not up get life expectancy up not
down and like get
the average cost of college uh down to a
point where
the average middle class family might
have a chance at um
actually sending their kid without
borrowing hundreds of thousands you know
it's like
these should be the goals of the economy
environmental sustainability
uh would be a big one and i truly
believe that
this has to be the future and one thing
i'm excited about john
is that uh 42 percent of the folks who
were supporting me in the presidential
weren't sure they're going to support
the nominee which means
we drew in a lot of folks who were from
all over the map
ideologically like a lot of fans who
were
libertarians or trump voters or
politically disengaged or whatever it
was
and i'm convinced that a lot of it was
because we have this political language
on each side and then i created this
kind of new
strange language of facts and figures
and economic trends and like
and it wasn't even deliberate on my part
i just
communicated the way i communicate and
it turns out that
there was like this untapped um
audience uh where they they looked up
and said
i don't like politics ordinarily but i
like what that guy is saying
uh and one of the points that ezra makes
in his book is that and you made it also
is that
right now politics is about um what team
you're on or what my support for this
policy says about me
and if you're politically disengaged
you actually respond to a message based
upon what it can do for you
as a family and people heard my thousand
dollars a month and said that is
actually going to do more for me than
these other things yeah but tell me were
your supporters
were they more educated than others or
were they
more the kind of people who would
benefit who really needed the thousand
dollars a month
my supporters were very diverse where we
had a lot of
highly educated support but we
had a lot of support from folks who
would benefit greatly
from that kind of policy and when we
looked at the top
five professions of the people who
donated to my campaign
i think they were and i didn't get i'm
not going to get the order right
but the top five were teacher
computer programmer driver
uh retail and
warehouse fulfillment i think so it
really
ran the gamut yeah that makes that makes
sense
uh you know because we often think that
politics is about voting for your
self-interest
and for some people it is um and if
especially people who are hurting if
they
get the sense that you you could really
help them and people like them
um but also american politics at the
presidential level
is more like a religion where we're we
want to be inspired
uh um uh and so
it makes sense that your campaign in
particular would attract a very diverse
group
um the the extent that you were the most
data driven the most you know
geeky i i suppose i mean you've got your
math cap right behind you uh
in the in the video other one being the
geekiest candidate sure
yeah that's right yeah so uh yeah so
people who care a lot about
the uh data and evidence didn't yeah
didn't really have uh
they yeah you were you were the guy to
go to for that
i was the math guy i was the math guy
tell me a bit more about it like what
would you actually do
um to to to change america or american
capitalism over to human-centered
it's not that hard uh so the main thing
you have to do
is actually shift the measurements of
the economy at the bureau of economic
analysis
via the department of commerce so right
now the department of commerce
reports on various measurements that we
use and the three main ones that our
media
makes use of are gdp
headline unemployment and stock market
prices
and each of those data points is
misleading at best uh and completely
destructive at worst so gdp
goes up if you have a natural disaster
because you have to invest in trying to
rebuild that town
if you have software that can drive
trucks it's going to be great for gdp
it's going to be very very bad for
lots of former drivers and even the
inventor of gdp said this is a terrible
measurement for national well-being and
we should never use it as that and he
said that
almost 90 years ago and here we are
writing it off a cliff
so that that's not great headline
unemployment
obscures so much it obscures
people who are out of the workforce
labor force participation is down to a
multi-decade low
even pre-pandemic it was around 63
percent which is
comparable to el salvador as an
international
reference uh millions of people have
dropped out of the workforce
it doesn't include folks who are
underemployed if you're underemployed
counts as a job if you're a gig worker
doing multiple jobs no benefits counts
as a job
so if you flip over the headline
unemployment it's almost
intentionally designed to be punitive
because if you drop out of the workforce
you no longer exist
it's kind of framing this world that uh
that
you know someone dreamed up decades ago
um so there are better measurements
labor force on uh participation would be
a big one
um using a different rate like u6 as
opposed to u3 which is the the
different labels for u6 includes people
who are discouraged who are detached
from the workforce
who are underemployed and it's typically
something like twice as high
as the the rate that we we hear about
and the third thing is stock market
prices is totally obvious at this point
to anyone who's looking up where
uh the bottom eighty percent of
americans own eight percent of all stock
market wealth the bottom 48
own zero so if you're paying attention
to stock market wealth you're
essentially
just reflecting the fortunes of the top
20 of americans
so so imagine a world where the same
breathless zeal with which we report
those numbers
actually applied to mental health
childhood success rates
clean air and clean water uh health
adjusted life expectancy
infant mortality uh affordability
of a college education like you actually
had
those numbers out there and then people
would seize upon them
and comment on them with the same
frequency and emotion that they do like
the stock markets ups and downs
and that's actually not that hard to
pull off all you need to do is report
that data and then have your government
and media institutions
hold them up and as soon as you do that
then it exposes a lot
like if you start saying hey our life
expectancy has declined three of the
last four years because suicides and
drug overdoses
have both overtaken vehicle deaths for
the first time in american history it's
very hard to put a positive spin on that
like
you you put that out there and say well
we are actually falling apart
uh or some of the social measurements
that you referred to earlier
around the disintegration of the
american family and what that's actually
meant
in terms of outcomes and the fact that
of american children are now born to an
unmarried mother and what that means
like if you have numbers like that out
there then
again like right now we we've been
blinded
uh by a few massive misleading
measurements
and then told that things are great um
and i believe the pandemic may have a
positive effect in exposing
that stuff as nonsense really like you
know because it's very hard to
imagine that things are going great and
the stock market at last i checked is
actually
uh doing just fine uh rfk robert kennedy
had a
beautiful uh beautiful speech about how
the gdp measures everything except that
which makes life worth living
it doesn't measure the joy of our
children's play uh the
the the value of our work like i think
they uh
the value of your wife taking care of
the kids yeah it doesn't get
any of that so yeah he's saying this in
the 60s
and here we are again almost six like 60
years later
um writing it off a cliff um so that to
me
was the path forward uh was like a
unifying vision
of what politics should be striving for
and one of the reasons why
i think this fact-based governance is so
important is right now we're devolving
into these
uh spin universes where i can argue for
whatever
results i want and you know it's like as
long as i say it really loud
then like you know people have to listen
to respect
so if you have a certain set of facts
that um you're centered on
and then if you're a republican you can
be trying to
gear policies towards slightly different
goals or even significantly different
goals
like you know you could be trying to
drive
a small business formation or military
readiness
or government efficiency or
family cohesion or whatever it is
as long as you have some goals you can
point to and say that's what we're
shooting for
um then and then if the other side wins
their election to be like okay we're
gonna shoot for
um for different goals uh you know like
uh that that are more around caring and
fairness
um then i think that would be okay
uh the problem right now is that um
facts are losing uh and and spin is
winning
i i came across the one just the
greatest insight on why that is
happening
uh recently i'd like to just read read a
few sentences to you
um so jonathan rauch at brookings uh
just a really brilliant
social analyst uh he was important in
the drive for gay marriage and
and um uh he
he has a book coming up called the
constitution of knowledge
and that's a bit of a play on words like
the constitution as like
the makeup of knowledge and then also
the constitution like the us
constitution like
what kind of structure do you need to
get knowledge and truth
and in uh in chapter eight the book will
come out a few months but i
he he sent me advanced copy of it look
at this we're gonna promote another book
i love it
if you think that you're part of the
reality-based community you need this
book now of course
if you think that's you you probably are
wrong on certain points
but um we are seeing a dramatic dramatic
uh decline in the anchoring
of political views to morality um
and so i just want to read you this quiz
this amazing quote
um about how social media came to play
such a role here
because he's focused on institutions uh
he says that's the key is getting
institute institutions that help us
you know check falsehood and so he says
um
uh uh the reality-based network's
institutional nodes
its filtering and pumping stations are
what give the system its positive
epistemic
valence that is its ability to
separate truth from falsehood and he
says the techno-utopians of the
information revolution
assumed that knowledge would
spontaneously emerge
from unmediated interactions across a
sprawling peer-to-peer network
with predictably disappointing results
without the places where professionals
like
experts and editors and peer reviewers
organize conversations and compare
propositions and assess competence
and provide accountability everywhere
from scientific journals to wikipedia
pages
there is no marketplace of ideas there
are only individuals running around
making noise
and that's what's happened to us as
social media became
really ubiquitous and much more
addictive after about 2009-2010
in the 2010s social media played a much
bigger role in our information ecosystem
and the
mainline media had to accommodate to it
and and
uh really changed as well um we don't
have
uh you know editors playing a role of
what's true and what's false
trump comes across think you know i
listen to the transcript of his his call
with a
raffenberg the guy in georgia and he
says you know he keeps saying
yeah well you know but uh you know they
they they burned up all these ballots so
that's what the rule that's
that's what i've heard like yeah sure
that's what you've heard
you know because you can hear anything
um so
i think you know technology and i know
you're you're strong on this too that
but you know that
if you want a good vibrant uh democracy
you need to be based in facts and truth
and evidence about what works
and social media is going to be a big
unders or the internet in general but
social media in particular
is going to be a big part of getting
that right
all right this episode of yank speaks is
brought to you by the new yorker
so one of the things andrew and i like
to do is find you guys great deals
on stuff we like and during the
presidential campaign we actually
liked the coverage we got from the new
yorker and frankly
um it's a it's a outlet that i've really
enjoyed
um because i think it it covers the news
well of course but it also covers like
different angles with it's arts and
culture and
there's a little bit of humor and comedy
i love their cartoons um
and they've become this kind of daily
destination for news and cultural
generally so um they've got 10 to 15
like site exclusive stories
every day so there's stuff you can only
get with them and they've got a ton
of good writers so um ronan farrow i
think
um is one of the most interesting
writers on the planet and is a big big
name for new yorker and there's a couple
other articles i was reading recently
that i really really liked uh there was
one on the difference between barack
obama and aoc i thought was fascinating
there was another one on the queen's
gambit it feels you watching netflix
uh it's called the fatal flaw of queen's
game and how it tracks the novel and why
it's different
and then they did a really interesting
piece a couple weeks ago on why venture
capitalism
is kind of distorting
capitalism um in our markets today which
is something andrew and i have talked a
lot about both on the trail and on this
podcast so
here's the deal for a limited time you
can get 12 weeks of the new yorker for
six
bucks that's 50 savings it's pretty
awesome
um and then listeners of this show also
get a tote bag
for free so go to new yorker.com yang
that's n-e-w-y-o-r-k
dot com slash and get 12 weeks new
yorker for six freaking bucks
and get a tote bag win-win six dollar
tote bag if you really want to look at
it
uh plus new yorker for free so
newyorker.com
[Music]
[Applause]
one thing i love about you john is that
you're not just a thinker you're a doer
like when you put these ideas out first
you know you do ted talks and you do
things we're actually trying to
broadcast the ideas to a general
audience you're not writing for like a
small insular group
but then you've actually founded a
number of organizations
uh to try and solve some of these
problems uh
now i agree with you completely that
we've taken
this uh polarized society and then we've
accelerated and exacerbated it uh
through
media and social media making it so that
you're rewarded for
uh inflammatory content you're rewarded
for
attacks on others you're awarded for uh
being sensationalist
so so so they're all these problems that
are now
compounding on each other uh and you
know
i ran for president saying okay look
like there's this fundamental economic
uh transformation that's happening that
we are not meaningfully addressing
and it's destroying us and it's going to
drive us insane
um which i believe and then then you
have
like media and social media dynamics on
top of it
um i sense that you and i agree on a lot
of this
but we're also problem solvers and doers
you know and we're also parents we're
looking up being like okay
my society is not uh faring that well
like it's coming apart not coming
together um
so so how can people support your work
aside from um from from buying some of
your books
following you and you're you're fun
where like you use social media but
you're very judicious about it
[Laughter]
like some of us it would be quite ironic
if you were like a very very
um heavy user uh but
uh talk about the work you're doing and
how people can
both keep up with you and support you
because you're doing incredible work
okay sure
well i've co-founded four organizations
to address different
aspects of of these institutional
failures that we have in america
so one is called ethical systems.org
it's something i founded with a bunch of
other researchers
uh in business schools and our goal is
to help companies improve business
ethics
and increasingly it's it's become to be
much more of a
stakeholder focus rather than
shareholder primacy that's the big
change that america needs to make
and that's just another way of saying
what you said about financialization and
love it stakeholder stakeholder models
instead of just a blind
shareholder value maximization which is
going to destroy us ethical systems
that's number one ethical systems.org
uh and then um because as i said before
i noted that
that my field of social psychology was
becoming sort of politically purified
everybody was on the left and i gave a
talk on that and i met a bunch of other
professors who were studying the problem
and we founded a site called
heterodoxacademy.org
so heterodox is the opposite of orthodox
do you want an orthodox academy where
people only say what is
you know the orthodox truth or do you
want a heterodox academy
in which professors and students you
know connect are exposed to all kinds of
different viewpoints
so if there are any faculty any
professors uh
listening we have a 5 000 members almost
all our professors
please go to heterodoxacademy.org or if
you want us if you are concerned about
the state of universities please
you know donate money or get on our
mailing list that's two
out of heterodox academy we created a
thing called open mind
to to teach that you know to expose
students to the best ideas of left right
and libertarian
and that turn it turns out the market
for that is not just at universities
it's actually mostly in businesses
businesses are being torn apart now
by by left-right politics especially in
in
tech media journalism the arts there are
a lot of industries now that are really
having
huge internal struggles over politics
and so if you go to openmindplatform.org
it's a free resource um you get a link
you send it out to your people
you'll all get a common vocabulary and
understanding of basic principles of
moral psychology that's the third
openmindplatform.org
and the fourth uh is uh coming out in
part from
my book the coddling of the american
mind with greg lukianov
where big fans of lenora skanasi
who wrote the book free range kids she
let her son
ride the subway alone when he was nine
and people freaked out
you know but she's been really the
apostle of you know what kids always
used to do this kids always used to go
outside without
an adult guard um they still do in some
parts of the world
yeah that's right and there are some
rural areas in of america where they do
but uh but almost but in most parts of
america we
suddenly got the idea even though crime
has been plummeting
you know since the 90s it's gotten safer
and safer this is the safest time to let
your kids out but we just freak out
apart from social media and other
but a lot of other trends at any rate so
a lot of reasons
as a parent i see so much programming
for kids warning them about strangers
like it's just you know stranger danger
don't
like don't take the thing it's very very
yeah do you know how many people do you
know how many documented cases there are
of poisoned halloween candy
zero i'm going to say zero right yeah
there are no known cases
and you know cases of child abduction
are extremely rare it's almost always
the non-custodial parent
anyway the point is uh we freak out we
we
keep our kids supervised and that means
they don't get to grow and learn
and this might be one of the reasons why
rates of anxiety and depression are
skyrocketing in gen z
kids born after 1995. so um
so with lenore skenezy and i and peter
gray and
daniel shukman founded an organization
called let grow
so if you go to letgrow.org if you have
kids who are in eighth grade or below
please go to letgrow.org and we've got
lots of tips for you and your family
uh how to foster your kids growing
independence
you know i live here in greenwich
village uh we let our kids walk to
school
uh when they were in fourth grade um
which you know when i was a kid you'd be
walking to school much earlier than that
but
uh but it was a big fourth grade's
pretty aggressive now and now 2021.
we had to give them a little card you
know saying that they have
permission from their parents because if
they get stopped you know child
protective services could
pay us a visit anyway if you're
concerned about these issues uh please
go to lecro.org and we
we're certainly in need of financial
support as well
letgrow.org such incredible
organizations
i'm going to just ask because i'm
curious so
your book cuddling of the american mind
came out in 2018
which i thought was a phenomenal
contribution
but i know the way your mind works like
you you are
a thinker and academic i can't help but
think that you've got some other
ideas uh germinating that are going to
eventually end up making it into the
world
uh it might be around technology it
might be i know we have mutual friends
who are
very concerned about uh the impact of
social media
um but like what what is uh
what what is attracting you right now or
what are you working on
my next book is going to be called three
stories about capitalism
the moral psychology of economic life um
because when i got to stern i was at the
university of virginia for most of my
career and then i came
to nyu stern in 2011 just for one year
originally
and as soon as i got here occupy wall
street broke out
so you have this really anti-capitalist
narrative there's a very clear story
which goes back thousands of years
that the rich are rich because they took
it from the poor that's that's
the first story of capitalism it's
exploitation but i was at the business
school here
where it's all about creating value and
you know
using business to solve social problems
and it's all very positive
and that's that's the story number two
is that capitalism is liberation
capitalism creates this explosive growth
that lifts everybody
not evenly but it does lift everybody
that's the second story
uh and so um you know
and in general the left likes the first
story the right leg's the second story
and so
i began to see the righteous mind stuff
playing out in economists and economic
arguments
that people would pick their facts to
support one story or the other
um yeah and uh so i i i proposed writing
a
book on this i got a contract in 2014
the book was due in 2017.
uh but i got kind of i got kind of
sidetracked because the
you know because the calling in american
mind that was an atlantic article in
2015 but it really
took off and the problem got worse so i
i i wrote that book
and put this one off i'm so glad i put
off the capitalism book because my god
everything has changed in the last year
and now suddenly there's much more
receptivity to human-centered capitalism
uh patient capitalism inclusive
capitalism
you know so i i don't know what the
third story is yet i i'm i'm
i've sort of staked it's human-centered
capitalism i'm gonna make a case for it
basically
send you some stuff okay great perfect i
will interview you for the book
um but that's what i'm working on next
because you know what i've really come
to see like
you know i i moved to a business school
when i was about 47 years old
and you know i'm i'm a pretty
well-educated american which meant i
knew nothing about capitalism
uh and um uh and i even kind of like
looked down on you know business schools
and capitalism
there's a kind of a snobbery in
universities where you know most people
think that business is too applied it's
not intellectual
but i've discovered that that was really
not true and i've really had a great
time
here at nyu stern my department is
called the business and society program
and we have one program looking at
business and human rights trying to help
companies
improve the supply chain which has
massive effects on the welfare of people
all over the world
uh and then we have uh tonsi weyland
used to run the rainforest alliance she
runs the
center for sustainable business uh and
if you know and if if businesses
improve you know improve their
sustainability
we all benefit uh and in most cases they
have a higher return on investment as
well anyway so
that's what i'm you know i'm a professor
in a business school and i'm doing all
this politics stuff all this childhood
stuff
uh but i'm also doing a lot of a lot of
stuff on on business and capitalism
well would certainly love to be helpful
um my evolution has
sort of gone the opposite direction john
where i ran out of private companies
yeah yeah and then i started a
non-profit
to help uh support entrepreneurs
and then i became convinced that the
biggest problems that are
coming down the pike are non-market
based problems
where if you have an opportunity to make
money by
getting groceries to people in their
homes or like delivering a service over
an app then there's
capital for you there's a marketplace
for it but a lot of the biggest problems
we're facing now don't have market-based
solutions
and so i got driven towards
politics that way where i'm convinced
that our economic system needs to evolve
very very quickly and significantly
and that there's not a realistic way to
do that that does not involve
uh massive wholesale political change
that's why i did something as rashes run
for president but it's fun like you and
i are arriving at a lot of the same
conclusions from different angles
that's right we're basically you know
pro-capitalism but recognizing its flaws
and um uh and i think you know one thing
that we've really learned in this
pandemic year
is not that government is the answer but
that when government works with
business amazing things happen uh and
that um
you know a lot of the market won't solve
many of our biggest problems
so you know again you you gotta break
the binary in fact there's a wonderful
book coming out
um um called high conflict
by amanda ripley and it's all about
how people get into these not these
conflicts that make them blind and it's
really unproductive and she talks about
complicating the narrative
the way you get people to think is not
by showing them well here's what one
side says and here's what the other side
says what do you think
because people tend to take one or the
other it's rather to say
you know well here's one group and
they've got a variety of opinions and
some of them think this and some of them
think that and you know
and to make it clear there's no easy
answer uh
but the and the answer might be
distributed so i think that's
that's what your candidacy did is you
know it you weren't like from one camp
or the other
but you're looking for answers from
multiple places
so if we're going to change if we're
going to change capitalism to be more
effective i mean the shorthand i use is
is that the third story is going to be
about capitalism that has high dynamism
and decency
you got to have both and the right take
it dynamism and decency yeah because the
right has always stood for dynamism even
at the cost of decency they don't
they don't care as much about the safety
net and the left always goes for decency
and they're willing to sacrifice
dynamism and have lower you know lower
uh
you know lower economic growth and and
and dynamism and decency are are
sometimes opposed to each other
um but a lot of places a lot of
businesses have found ways to
avoid that scandinavia um the fact they
have such a good
that they have they have probably the
best combination of dynamism and decency
because they're very very decent
societies but they also have their uh
sweden in particular they're pretty
dynamic economically
and so uh well what we've done right now
is we've we've
given all of the incentives to dynamism
and then said but but try and be decent
you know it's like we have to try and
make it so that you could actually be
rewarded for being decent
uh as a business uh or business leader
well john thank you so much uh i learned
so much from you
i feel privileged to have had this time
with you uh and
hopefully you will continue to just keep
on making me and everyone else smarter
um i'm just gonna continue to ping you
learn from you
anything you do i want to see and read
and support yeah my pleasure andrew i
really enjoyed talking with you
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeaks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you